So Dr. Zaki, the first question I'd like
to um draw your attention to is
regarding the use of the right hand over
the left, which I understand is a
sunnah. Inshallah, you're going to
explain that. Can you explain why the
right hand is preferred in such things
as eating, greeting, and other things
and the left is not uh preferred at all.
>> Alhamdulillah.
as far as right hand being preferred in
Islam, the things which are honorable,
the things which are mustab, the things
which get blessings, the things which
are good are supposed to done with the
right hand and the others like cleaning
etc supposed to with the left hand and
accord According to the sunnah of the
prophet Mus wasallam, we have to eat
with the right hand. We have to drink
with the right hand. We have to shake
hands with the right hand. And a person
when he wears a garment, he should wear
the right hand side first. If he's
wearing a shirt, it should be right hand
first. If he's wearing a trouser, then
right leg first. If he's wearing a
footwear, again the right leg first. And
similarly, when a person is doing
voodoo, the right limb should be first.
The right hand first then the left hand.
The right leg first then the left leg.
While you're entering the masjid, it
should be with the right foot. If you're
completing salah and doing salam, then
the right side first. If you're touching
the black stone, it should be with the
right hand. If you're combing your hair,
then right side. Trimming a mustache,
right side. Cutting the nails, right
hand first. If you're removing the
unwanted hair from the body, again,
right side first. If it's shaving the
head, then again, right side first.
And if you're exiting the toilet,
it is right leg first. And if you're
putting cohel in your eyes, again the
right side first. And
if you are doing miswak, if you're doing
savak, then again right side first. So
these are the sunnas of the prophet
which the prophet has taught us. And as
I mentioned that the things which are to
clean and which are not honorable,
that's with the left hand. For example,
when removing your garments, it is the
left side first. removing a shirt then
left hand. If you're removing your
trouser left leg if you're removing your
footwear then again left leg and left
foot first. You are exiting the mosque
then the left leg. If entering the
toilet again left leg if you're cleaning
maybe going to the toilet and cleaning
your part of the body then again it is
the left hand. If you're blowing the
nose it's left hand. So this is the
differentiation and you find several
hadith mentioned in these things. It's
mentioned in the hadith of Sai Bkhari
volume number seven in the book of foods
hadith number 5376
where the beloved prophet wasallam says
he says to a young boy that say
bismillah before eating take the name of
Allah before eating eat with the right
hand and eat what is next to you it's
mentioned say Muslim volume number three
in the book of drinks hadith number 5010
the prophet said
which means do not eat and drink with
the left hand for the Satan eats and
drinks with the left hand. So that is
the reason you see that most of the
Muslims who follow the sunnah and our
pas they don't eat and drink with the
left hand. But normally when we have our
food when we having lunch having dinner
with having with their hands and if you
want to drink water most of the people
because their right hand is dirty they
have with the left hand but in order to
follow the hadith they put the right
hand down. So you might have noticed
that instead of having directly they put
the left hand and put the right hand
down so that you know it indicates
having with the right hand so that don't
dirty the glass but nasurbani he has
objection to this he says that if the
hadith would have said that drink with
the right hand or eat with the right
hand then the act would not be right.
What the hadith says wasallam do not
drink and eat with the left hand for the
satan eats and drinks with the left
hand. So even doing this he objects he
says even though your right hand is
dirty you can pick up the glass with the
right hand because it's preferable to
dirty the glass then to dirty the soul.
So he even disagrees having with the
left hand and putting your right hand
below. He said have it directly with the
right hand. If the glass gets dirty no
problem it's preferable to dirty the
glass then dirty the soul. This is the
difference of opinion that shikasalmani
has. May Allah have mercy on him.
Furthermore, it's mentioned in the
hadith of Abu Dha in the book of foods
had number 4129. The beloved prophet
wasallam said that use the right side
first while you're doing voodoo and
while you are putting on a garment. The
prophet said use your right hand first
when you're putting on a garment and
when you're doing voodoo and then you
can use the left later on. Further it's
mentioned in the hadith of Abu Dawud
volume number one had number 33 it's
mentioned that Muhammad sallallahu
alaihi wasallam said that you should use
your right hand for getting food and use
your right hand for doing ablution
right side first and then use the left
side and if you're washing then use the
left side and further mentioned in the
hadith of say Muslim had number 504 the
beloved prophet said that do not use the
right hands for things like washing etc.
You have to use the left hand for things
like washing etc. And based on this
mashallah it's a sunnah that as I
mentioned we do good things and
honorable things the must think the
right hand and the other with the left
hand and regarding the logic behind this
is that medical science tells us today
that the left side of the brain it
controls the right side of the body and
the right side of the brain it controls
the left half of the body and today's
science tells us that more than 90% of
the human beings Their left hemisphere
of the brain is dominant. That's the
reason more than 90% of the human beings
they are righty but the left side of the
brain is dominant. So most of the things
that people do whether Muslim or
non-Muslim they use the right side. But
Islam encourages us for doing the good
things with the right hand and the
things which are cleaning etc use the
left side. And the reason is that
normally most of the people use only
left hemisphere of the brain because
they're righty. But Islam encourag us to
use right hand right side of the body
for the good things. But even tells us
to use the left side for doing things
which are not honorable for things which
opposite. So here a human being besides
doing things the good things right hand
he is forced to use his left side for
example while exiting the mosque you
have to exit with the left foot for
entering the toilet you have to enter
with the left foot. So here we make a
conscious effort for example removing
the garment normally people use the
right hand they put the garment with the
right hand and remove with the right
side. This is a normal habit. So here we
deliberately
consciously use the left side for
removing the garment, left side for
removing the footwear. So here we are
even utilizing the other part of the
brain though less than the right side.
So it gives a good exercise to the brain
and it is much more better for the
brain. So scientifically also it's
better what the prophet said more things
we do with the right hand but we
consciously do certain things with the
left hand. So that is a good nourishment
and exercise for the brain.